hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es das
Pfannen und Töpfe Video von mir woran
man gute Pfannen erkennt und warum ich
meine eigenen auf den Markt gebracht
habe das werde ich heute erläutern und
warum ich vor allem jetzt zwei Jahre
nachdem ich meine Pfannen und Töpfe
gelauncht habe erst dieses Video drehe
das sage ich euch am Ende des Videos
denn das hat auch einen besonderen Grund
und ich würde jetzt einfach mal alle
Fragen beantworten die ihr mir so im
Laufe der Zeit gestellt habt viele sind
auch schon online beantwortet worden auf
der Webseite ich verlinke sie euch hier
unten in die Infobox und falls am Ende
dieses Videos auch noch Fragen
auftauchen sollten dann schreibt mir und
ich beantworte sie euch gerne so bevor
ich euch ins Video entlasse bleibt bis
zum Schluss dran denn ihr habt mir auf
Instagram so viele Nachrichten
geschrieben und ich habe mir gedacht
okay warum nicht wir machen auch noch
einen Gewinnspiel am Anschluss des
Videos also in all der riesenflut von
Fun und Töpfen habe ich mir gedacht okay
muss das jetzt sein dass ich meine
eigene noch rausbringe und entwickle ja
auf jeden Fall weil ich war in den
letzten Jahren immer super unzufrieden
und wollte eigentlich mit meinem Vater
und Töpfen all das verändern und
verbessern was mich in den letzten
Jahren einfach mega gestört hat und das
hat einige Zeit gedauert also wie gesagt
rausgebracht habe ich sie vor ca 2
Jahren aber angefangen hat die Reise
schon vor dreieinhalb Jahren also wir
starten mit dem Material da war mir
wichtig dass das Material einfach extrem
robust ist und man sich nicht jedes Jahr
aufs Neue eine neue Pfanne oder einen
neuen Topf kaufen muss dann hat man
lieber einmal was von Qualität und
behält das jahrelang wenn nicht sogar
ein Leben lang es kommt natürlich darauf
an wie oft ihr sie verwendet ich benutze
meine Pfanne und Töpfe schon Hardcore
oft also ich mache das ja ich bin ja
nicht nur beruflich immer in der Küche
sondern benutzt sie dann auch privat
immer noch weiter und benutzt sie
eigentlich so wie eine ganze
Fußballmannschaft das benutzen würde und
ich habe sie noch nie austauschen müssen
das heißt ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel
diese eine Pfanne und das ist auch immer
noch diese eine Pfanne ich werde es ich
tausche jetzt nicht für die Videos aus
oder habe dann jedes Mal eine neue damit
sie einfach wieder gut aussieht das ist
eine aluguss-pfanne und zwar wird sie
per Hand gegossen in der Produktion die
in Deutschland stattfindet da gehe ich
später noch näher drauf ein sind mehrere
Menschen beteiligt das sind acht bis
neun Personen an ein so einer Pfanne
dran beteiligt also jeder hat da so
seinen Aufgabenbereich und die hier wird
mit einem Kokillenguss Verfahren
gegossen das heißt wirklich jede Pfanne
und jeder Topf wird per Hand gegossen
alle fahren und Töpfe sind auch für alle
Herdarten geeignet Gas Ceran Induktion
also alle die euch vorstellen können und
auch für den Backofen dann möchte ich
gleich näher drauf eingehen jetzt noch
mal zu dem Boden der hat einen
Thermoboden acht bis neun Millimeter ist
der dick und hat dadurch einfach die
perfekte light Wärmeleitfähigkeit aber
speichert auch die Wärme perfekt so
jetzt müsst ihr euch überlegen was es
euch wichtiger früher hatte ich fanden
und Töpfe einer anderen großen Weltfirma
das waren auch die die ich immer nach
neuen oder zehn Monaten entsorgen musste
weil sie einfach zu zerkratzt waren und
nicht mehr gut waren und jetzt habe ich
ja eben meine eigenen was ist euch
wichtiger dass euer Reis zum Beispiel
schneller fertig wird also bei meinen
alten Töpfen und Pfannen von der anderen
Firma hat wann die bei der Reise immer
noch 18 Minuten perfekt gar und
anschließend aber super schnell wieder
kalt hier brauche ich 22 Minuten für die
gleiche Portion Reis aber dafür ist mein
Reis super lange warm das heißt wenn ich
Gäste habe oder auch einfach selber
später esse habe ich einfach nach einer
Stunde immer noch schön warm Reis und
das war mir persönlich wichtig und daher
habe ich auch insbesondere hier auf das
Material geachtet das allerwichtigste
neben Material neben Nachhaltigkeit und
Co ist natürlich auch die Beschichtung
ich weiß es viele in Pfannen und Töpfe
reingehen ohne irgendwie drauf zu achten
dass es jetzt unbedingt aus Silikon ist
der Kochlöffel oder aus Holz ich wollte
einfach dass man da ohne sich Gedanken
machen zu müssen auch mal mit Eisen oder
mit Edelstahl reingehen kann und das
funktioniert hier weil wir haben eine
peek-beschichtung das ist eigentlich das
höchste was man bekommen kann dass das
Beste was man kriegen kann die
Beschichtung kann noch nicht mal ein
Sandstrahler zerstören das heißt nicht
dass ihr irgendwann da bin ich ja immer
ganz ehrlich zu euch und möchte dass ihr
das auch wisst das heißt nicht dass sie
irgendwann wenn ihr da immer mit dem
Edelstahl Schneebesen reingeht was ich
auch mache oberfläch Kratzer bekommen
können also das kann definitiv passieren
was aber nicht passieren kann und das
unter keinen Umständen dass ihr diese
Schicht so durchdringt dass irgendwann
gesundheitsschädliche Stoffe in euer
Essen gelangen können das ist komplett
ausgeschlossen die Beschichtung geht mit
diesem Gusskörper so eine enge
Verbindung ein dass es unmöglich ist
quasi da diese Beschichtung tiefer zu
durchdringen es ist wenn überhaupt eine
oberflächlich außerdem haben meine
Produkte alle eine Antihaftversiegelung
das heißt ihr könnt hier mit komplett
fettfrei kochen ihr könnt doch euer
Omelett zum Beispiel wieder um darauf
zurückzukommen komplett ohne Öl ohne
Butter anbraten oder auch ganz ganz
fettarm darin kochen das ist überhaupt
kein Problem meine Mama hat mir das
Feedback gegeben dass immer wenn sie
Joghurt macht sie macht den nämlich
immer selbst das bei ihren alten Töpfen
immer die Milch ganz schnell unten
angepappt ist und das passiert ihr mit
meinen Töpfen gar nicht mehr sie muss
auch nicht jede Sekunde dranbleiben und
sie kann auch wirklich mal sich um
andere Dinge kümmern denn es ist quasi
unmöglich dass hier die Milch habt unten
aufgrund der extrem guten antihaft
Eigenschaften es sei denn man stellt
sich wirklich extrem unerfahren an aber
das kann eigentlich gar nicht passieren
das gleiche fällt mir beim Brandteig auf
normalerweise hat man beim Brandteig
immer unten diese weiße Schicht und das
entfällt hier das heißt wenn ihr
Brandteig macht nach meinem Rezept und
meine Töpfe verwendet dann bekommt ihr
diese weiße brennschicht gar nicht der
Teig funktioniert trotzdem aber aufgrund
der extrem guten antihaft Eigenschaft
pappt da einfach unten gar nichts an so
Funktionalität habe ich euch ja jetzt
auch schon einiges erklärt aber was ich
auch mega cool finde ist dass man hier
einfach komplett den Griff abnehmen kann
zum einen ist jetzt auch meine Pfanne
komplett Backofen geeignet samt Deckel
natürlich und zum anderen ist es auch
extrem platzsparend das heißt ich habe
noch nie so viele funn und Töpfe in
meiner Schublade unterbekommen wie mit
meinen und da kann ich mal den Griff
einfach noch mal in so eine Halterung
reintun und jeder Griff passt auch auf
jede Pfanne egal ob groß oder klein
dadurch dass jetzt der Griff nicht in
den Backofen kommt denn das darf er
nicht können wir das hier für
Schmorgerichte Aufläufe etc oder auch
für Kuchen verwenden das ist auch kein
Problem und das Ganze ist hitzebeständig
bis 240 Grad mit Deckel was aber auch
nur am Deckel liegt denn meine Töpfe und
fand könnt ihr sogar bis 300 Grad in den
Backofen schieben also kurz zur Auswahl
wir haben ja gestartet mit zwei Töpfen
und zwei Pfannen und jetzt hat sich das
so ein bisschen erweitert das Sortiment
weil wir natürlich auf euch hören was
jetzt ganz neu dazu gekommen ist da habt
ihr mich wirklich bombardiert mit
Nachrichten ist die 28er Pfanne die sind
sehr schwer was aber auch sehr gut ist
und die hat auch bewusst einen höheren
Rand das heißt ihr könnt darin wirklich
für sehr viele kochen und was ich auch
ganz neu habe bzw das heißt ganz neu
seit ein paar Monaten aber es ist schon
relativ neu ist einmal unsere Wokpfanne
die hat auch ein abnehmbaren Griff also
das könnt ihr dann quasi auch wieder in
den Ofen schieben wenn ihr mögt und
endlich mal eine Wokpfanne wo es
wirklich komplett abger gut ist und
nicht unten komplett flach und dann geht
es an den Seiten hoch genau da könnte
schön eure Wok Gerichte drin schwenken
und hier unser beliebtester Neuzugang
muss ich sagen ist hier die Grillpfanne
des rechteckig die hatte noch diese
Rillen und hat auch wieder mal den
abnehmbaren Griff damit kann man auch
ganz gut Fleisch etc machen auch Gemüse
dünsten etc also ja das so zur Auswahl
ich bin in einem mehr voller Töpfe und
Fun so Frage wie man das ganze jetzt
reinigt tatsächlich braucht ihr wenn ihr
normalen Kochvorgang habt teilweise
nicht mal mehr Spülmittel weil das so
eine gute antihaft Eigenschaft hat das
warmes Wasser nur reicht wenn ihr aber
leichte Verschmutzungen habt nimmt ein
bisschen Spülmittel und Wasser meine
Pfannen und Töpfe dürfen auch alle in
die Spülmaschine aber ich sage immer
alles was euch lieb ist am besten kurz
mit der Hand spülen und so habt ihr auch
den Platz in der Spülmaschine gespart
und wenn es doch mal in die Spülmaschine
gibt aus Zeitmangel etc dann am besten
nach dem Spülvorgang sofort rausnehmen
und einmal abtrocknen weil gerade hier
im Hintergrund die seht ihr ja auch
quasi mein Stempel made in Germany
kitchen da kann ja manchmal auch ein
bisschen Wasser sich absetzen das heißt
immer schön abtrocknen hat man auch
keine Wasserflecken apropos made in
Germany da bin ich so stolz drauf weil
man hätte natürlich auch ins Ausland
gehen können natürlich spart man sich da
auch ein bisschen was an vielleicht
Lohnkosten gerade der Mensch ist
eigentlich das teuerste in so einer
Produktion natürlich auch die
Materialien etc aber ich habe euch ja
vorhin schon gesagt 8 bis 9 Menschen
sind an der Produktion von dieser einen
Pfanne beteiligt und ich wollte
unbedingt eine Produktionsstätte finden
die auf meine Wünsche eingeht und
deshalb habe ich auch anfangs gesagt es
ist nicht so dass ich jetzt gerade vor
zwei Jahren oder auch vor einem Jahren
Video gemacht habe weil ich weiß dass
dann natürlich auch das Interesse wieder
steigt und natürlich auch die Pfannen
und Töpfe dann doof ist auch klingt aber
es ist jetzt einfach mal ehrlich gesagt
besser verkauft werden das ist gar nicht
so das Ziel weil ich bin einfach dankbar
dass ich die habe dass ich sie selber
besitze dass ich sie meiner Mama geben
kann und meiner Familie und dass ich sie
auch natürlich euch präsentieren kann
aber wir können nicht so machen dann
werden die produziert wenn die einmal
ausverkauft sind dann sind sie für
Monate ausverkauft die komplette
Produktionsstätte wird einmal umgestellt
damit das nach meinen Anforderungen
hergestellt wird natürlich gibt es auch
andere Firmen die in dieser
Produktionsstätte Waren produzieren
lassen aber auf einem ganz anderen Level
ich habe da einfach diese extrem
Ansprüche und daher habe ich mir Zeit
gelassen wie gesagt wenn die mal
vergriffen sind sind sie auch wirklich
nicht da weil es Monate Vorlauf brauchen
müssen die Materialien einkaufen müssen
die gesamte Produktion einmal nur für
meine Ansprüche umstellen und dann sind
sie auch wieder da also ich hoffe dass
es euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
wenn ihr Fragen habt schreibt sie gerne
in die Kommentare ganz wichtig ist mir
noch das Thema made in Germany um das
noch mal zu unterstreichen es gibt
natürlich auch ein Trick und das finde
ich immer total blöd und ein bisschen
auch beschämend das ist Menschen oder
Firmen gibt die lassen zum Beispiel ein
Teil hier von irgendeins sei es auch nur
dieses kleine Stück hier in in
Deutschland produzieren und alles andere
kommt dann aus dem Ausland und da darf
man das als made in Germany deklarieren
hier könnt ihr euch sicher sein dass
alles was hier dran ist zu 100% in
Deutschland hergestellt wird das einzige
was wir in Frankreich herstellen lassen
sind unsere Gläser das sind die
pyrexgläser die kennt man auch diesen
bekannt dafür dass die extrem robust und
sehr sehr gut sind ansonsten ist es
komplett zu 100% made in Germany und da
bin ich einfach stolz drauf also wenn
ihr wie gesagt noch Fragen habt schreibt
sie gerne in die Kommentare ich bin auch
nach Monaten und nach Jahren in den
Kommentaren aktiv und beantworte euch
alles ansonsten kommt halt auch immer
die Frage wie schwer sind die Pfannen
und Töpfe ja sie haben schon ordentlich
Gewicht und deswegen war das auch so ein
Anliegen dadurch dass wir jetzt den
Store in Bochum haben war das einfach so
ein Anliegen dass man das anfassen kann
und sich einfach mal einen Eindruck
verschaffen kann es ist so schwierig
online einzuschätzen ob die Qualität
jetzt wirklich gut ist oder nicht hier
kann ich euch sagen ich stehe zu 1000
Prozent mit Herz und Verstand dahinter
und ansonsten wenn ihr aus der Nähe
kommt oder mal in Bochum seid kommt
gerne in den Store und schaut euch die
Produkte mal an ansonsten danke ich fürs
zuhören und sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss eure Kiki ich verlose jetzt noch
eine 28er Pfanne mit Deckel und einen
26er Topf mit Deckel das heißt es gibt
zwei Gewinner die Chancen sind also
höher was müsst Ihr dafür tun seid
einfach Abonnent meines Kanals und
schreibt mir einen Kommentar schreibt
irgendein fact aus dem Video zu meinen
Fun und Töpfen und dann lose ich in
sieben Tagen die zwei Gewinner aus und
schreibe euch an viel Glück
[Musik]